the people versus shall that's how
environmental groups call the case after
people donated more than half a million
euros to help fund the court hearings
before this legal battle against one of
the world's most powerful corporations
got on the way
more money was being pledged the same
court in the hague ruled last year that
the dutch state should protect its
citizens
against the dangers of climate change it
ordered the netherlands to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions
with 25 percent compared to 1990 by the
end of this year
environmentalists see this verdict based
on a dutch law
as a president for the case against
royal dutch shell
in dutch law no company is allowed to
endanger the lives
of citizens through its actions that's
an
illegal and an ethical norm and we're
basing our court
case on that norm friends of the earth
say that more than 30 years ago
shell had secret knowledge about the sea
level rise caused by global warming and
as a result
raised the legs of oil platform troll a
near norway by 2 meters
despite this the group say the oil giant
continued to increase its production and
paid international lobbyists
to downplay the dangers shall declined
al jazeera's request to respond on
camera
but in its paper sent to the court the
company denies the accusations
we believe the claims in this summons
are inappropriate
and legally without foundation for
example they assert that the paris
agreement is directly binding on royal
dutch shell
and they allege that shell had unique or
special knowledge about
co2 related climate change these
allegations are not true
this court ruled last year that failing
to reduce global warming is a violation
of human rights
this time a company not a state is on
trial
if environmentalists can convince the
court that shell by
increasing its production of fossil
fuels is deliberately putting people's
lives at risk
this would have a major impact on the
fight against climate change
environmentalists are not seeking
compensation from shell
but want to force the company to change
its actions instead of investing 95
in fossil fuels they want shell to
increasingly invest in renewable energy
it makes it easier for the claimants
because one
very controversial issue in climate
change litigation is the issue of
causality can you prove that
there is a causal link between on the
one hand the behavior of
corporations and on the one hand
specific damage incurred by certain
individuals
whereas here that causality does not
need to be proven as such
the 2015 paris agreement states that a
temperature rise of more than one and a
half degrees will endanger the planet
with this case which could take years
environmentalists hope to prove that
child's actions are doing just that
step faster al jazeera the hague